♪
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX
NEWS ALERT.
AS WE JUST TOLD YOU, THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" RELEASED
TONIGHT NEW INFORMATION ON A
DECADE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
TAXES.
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS BEEN
TAKING A CLOSE LOOK AT WHAT
THEY PUT OUT THERE AND JOINS
US WITH AN UPDATE ON IT
TRACE?
>> HI, TUCKER.
WE'RE SCANNING THE ARTICLE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE OFF
THE TOP THE TAX RECORDS DO
NOT INCLUDE INFORMATION OR
TAX YEARS AT THE CENTER OF
THE PRESIDENT'S ESCALATING
BATTLE WITH CONGRESS.
THERE ARE NO ALLEGATIONS OF
CRIMES OR FINANCIAL
MISDEEDS.
INSTEAD, THE RECORDS GO BACK
TO THE LATE '80S, EARLY
'90s, YEARS THE PRESIDENT
HAS ALREADY ADMITTED WERE AT
THE VERY LEAST TUMULTUOUS.
BY THE TIME DONALD TRUMP'S
ART OF THE DEAL BOOK HIT
SHELVES IN 1987, HE WAS
ALREADY IN DEEP FINANCIAL
DISTRESS, MEANING TENS OF
MILLIONS IN DEBT AND DURING
THE DECADE FROM 1985 TO
1994, THE "TIMES" SAYS
TRUMP'S LOSSES TOTALED JUST
OVER $1.1 BILLION.
REMEMBER, THIS IS INVESTORS
AND LOAN MONEY PRIMARILY.
A FEW POINTS THERE.
DURING THAT TIME, MR. TRUMP
BOUGHT EASTERN AIRLINES
SHUTTLE FOR 365 MILLION.
IT NEVER TURNED A PROFIT.
AND HE WAS SPENDING UPWARDS
OF $7 MILLION A MONTH TO
KEEP IT UP AND FLYING.
AND HIS TAJ MAHAL HOTEL AND
CASINO IT OPENED IN 1990
WITH MORE THAN 800 MILLION
IN DEBT AND TO KEEP THE TAJ
FLOATING TRUMP'S BUSINESSES
PULLED MONEY FROM OTHER
CASINOS PLACING THEM IN THE
RED AS WELL.
NOW, THE "TIMES" IS
REPORTING BECAUSE OF ALL THE
LOSSES THAT TRUMP PAID NO
FEDERAL TAXES IN EIGHT OF
THE TEN YEARS.
CHARLES J. HARTER WHO IS A
LAWYER FOR THE PRESIDENT
TOLD THE "TIMES" ON SATURDAY
THAT THE INFORMATION WAS
DEMONSTRABLY FALSE AND THE
STATEMENTS ABOUT THE TAX
RETURNS 30 YEARS AGO ARE
HIGHLY INACCURATE SAYING,
AND I'M QUOTING HERE, IRS
TRANSCRIPTS, PARTICULARLY
BEFORE THE DAYS OF
ELECTRONIC FILING, ARE
NOTORIOUSLY INACCURATE AND
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
A REASONABLE PICTURE OF ANY
TAXPAYER'S RETURNS.
WE SHOULD ALSO POINT OUT THE
"TIMES" DID NOT OBTAIN THE
ACTUAL TAX RETURNS.
THEY GOT THE INFORMATION
FROM SOMEONE WHO IS
UNIDENTIFIED WHO HAD ACCESS
TO THE TAX INFORMATION.
WE'RE STILL SCANNING,
TUCKER.
IF WE COME UP WITH MORE
STUFF WE WILL BRING IT TO
YOU.